hey here's something interesting and I
want to applaud our audience about this
a couple of weeks ago we got a call from
a guy during our live call segment uh a
lawyer from Boston who said hey David I
work with a bunch of lawyers from
Argentina and I don't know whether I
should be calling them Argentine or
Argentinean when referring to them and I
explained I think the term is
Argentinian we're talking here uh about
uh the way that I grew up that the the
word I grew up using Argentine sounds
sort of very British to me it doesn't
really sound quite right Argentinian is
the word that i use and i got an email
from a viewer in the last few days that
someone this is the most subtle it's
just this is so subtle that i love it
someone went into my public Wikipedia
page right the page for david pakman and
they made a change which i'll put up on
the screen for you here they changed my
own wiki article from saying that david
pakman is an Argentine born American
host blah blah blah blah blah to an
Argentinian born and I cannot possibly
believe that this is complete chance
because it's been this way I think for
years right after we get a call and I go
listen guys the word is Argentinian the
wikipedia page is updated unbelievable
by means that this is not that this is
not a coincidence i believe anybody
think it's a coincidence now attention
to detail at its finest also by the way
i haven't looked at this for a while and
you can look on wikipedia to see when
there are edits made and there have been
some interesting sort of wiki fights
where someone will come in and make an
edit and then very quickly someone comes
in and undoes the Edit someone added
that i'm a democrat and then someone
very promptly removed it because i
actually am not a democrat and
progressive but i've never been a
registered member of the democratic
party uh all sorts of stuff and I think
we have a screenshot again of the before
and after on that someone saying a
political party Democrat and then very
very soon thereafter that being removed
so I don't know who on earth is
monitoring this page were so quickly
think things are being fixed but someone
requires some recognition for the fact
that they haven't Devon interest in
accuracy in the facts I'm going straight
for the Loch Ness monster here
Stephen chupacabra when which writer
said that there's no such thing as
coincidences I have no idea okay lots of
lawyers say that yeah interestingly
enough I don't know what we can deduce
from that